I hope everyone watching had an
excellent 2023 and is looking to get
2024 off to a rambun start this video
though has been made to show that we are
on the Steep part of the exponential and
will be for a while yet I'm going to
give you four clear reasons why though I
could have easily given eight or 16
depending on how you categorize them and
how much time you've got we will look at
how data quality will change everything
according to the famed authors of Mamba
and mix trial and then how models will
start to think before answering and
according to this fascinating new paper
just how much lwh hanging fruit there is
out there in AI that doesn't even
require more compute and even setting
all of that aside will end with the
explosion in multimodal progress that is
occurring around us that by the way will
include listening to a version of my
voice that you might find hard to
distinguish from my my real one I'll
also finish with some predictions for
the year ahead but I'm going to start
with Mamba but not yet the new
architecture that is causing shock waves
I'll cover that in a minute I'm going to
start with one of the co-authors tree da
and despite all the buzz about his new
architecture here's what he said about
data quality all the architecture stuff
is Fun making that Hardware ficient is
is is is fun U but I think ultimately is
about data if you if you look at the
scaling scaling law curve like the
architectures different mod
architectures would generally have the
same slope they're just different offset
seems like the only thing that changes
the slope is the uh data quality yes
we're going to cover Mamba in a minute
but for language modeling it does
perform better than the Transformer
Plus+ basically the best version of a
transformer but according to this graph
with five or 10 times as much compute
you could replicate the performance of
Mamba with a Transformer and all of this
remember is for a small 3 billion
parameter model we don't know what it
will be like at bigger sizes so for
language modeling potentially a big
breakthrough but data quality still
means more we are not even close to
maximizing the quality of data fed into
our models here's Arthur mench
co-founder of mistol the creators of
some of the most cuttingedge open-
Source AI models to increase data
efficiency you do need to work on coming
up with very high quality data filtering
things uh many new techniques that needs
to be invented still but that's really
where the lock is uh data is the one
important thing and the ability of the
model to decide how much computed want
to allocate to certain problem uh is
definitely on the frontier as well so
these are things that we're actively
looking at I'll speak more about letting
models think for longer and inference
time compute later on in this video but
if you still weren't convinced about the
importance of data quality here's
Sebastian bck who might be able to
persuade you in an interview for AI
Insiders on patreon that last slide that
you did on for your channel amazing
Channel where it was like a THX increase
in effective compute from parameters and
data it seems massive to me and I I
don't think enough people are
appreciating that point yeah I I think
it's pretty massive to be honest you
know before working on this line of work
I was thinking about improving the
optimization algorithm I was thinking
about impr in the architecture and I
worked on this for a few years and we
could get you know 2% 3% Improvement
like this small type of you know around
the edges still it's it's nice but it's
it's tiny but then suddenly when we
started to focus on the data and really
trying to craft data in a way that is
more digestible by the llm at training
time suddenly we saw this incredible
like you know thousand X gains so yes I
think I think it is massive and it's
really pointing to where the where where
the gold is and the gold is in the data
now at this point I know many of you
will be saying we get it philli data
quality is important but tell us about
the new architectures that might be
processing that data in other words tell
us about Mamba that's a new architecture
that has been generating a lot of buzz
in AI circles if not for the general
public I've been hoping to speak to one
of the only two authors on this paper in
the meantime I want to try to translate
its significance to the lay person I'm
going to try to convey what Mamba is and
what it means in Just 2 or 3 minutes
before we touch on the contender let's
talk about the king Transformers that's
the architecture behind everything from
Dar 3 to GPT 4 and Transformers are
famous in part because they're great at
paying attention in this diagram from
the famous Illustrated Transformer we
see that as we encode or process the
word it the Transformer architecture
pays attention to all of the previous
words or token some of course like
animal more than others and it will do
this for all of the words it's going to
encode and the truth is that paying
attention is great but the kind of
attention in Transformers where every
element must attend to every other
element is complex at Big scales in fact
it's called quadratic complexity and
whenever you hear that word quadratic
think Square you may remember the word
quadratic from school and the Y = x²
graph and hopefully that makes sense
because as you double the number of
elements you far more than double the
number of pairwise Connections in a very
rough analogy imagine everyone shaking
hands in a room and if you triple the
number of people in that large room you
are roughly N9 Xing 3 squared the number
of handshakes but now imagine sequences
of 1 million interconnected tokens no
one has that much attention to give but
there are other known ways to process a
sequence of inputs how about a state of
fixed size being updated by inputs step
by step it seems simpler right although
it's a lot less parallelizable that is a
hard word to say now there have been
attempts for quite a while to get the
best of both here's Albert goo one of
the lead authors of Mamba and his paper
from 2021 was called structured State
spaces for sequence modeling indeed that
4S's name had so much s sound sibilance
it inspired the mamba snake name but now
let's get to the m paper itself and the
key diagram therein there's that hidden
State on the left merrily processing its
way across to the right updated in turn
by the inputs coming in from here this
longlasting state needs to be a rich but
compressed expression of all of the data
seen so far but if this approach can be
made to work it would mean far fewer
connections to compute and therefore
faster inference indeed the paper claims
5x faster inference on nvidia's a100 and
without that quadratic complexity it
would mean that even extremely long
sequences think vast code bases DNA
sequences and even the video input from
a long YouTube explainer could now be
handled without a mental breakdown but
remember that state needs to compress
all the data it's seen including
therefore ignoring certain inputs and
that is where the selection mechanism
comes in it decides what inputs to
ignore and which to concentrate on the
trouble is this rich and expressive
hidden state with the distilled selected
inputs is slow to process and
computationally demanding so how did
treow keep this hidden State rich and
expressive with the distilled wisdom of
previous inputs how did they expand that
state without bringing everything to a
standstill well by painting it orange no
but seriously what orange means in the
diagram is that it's processed in the
GPU U SRAM think of that as the super
fast part of the gpu's memory with the
shortest commute to the processing chip
in contrast all the model parameters in
green which won't change and the inputs
can be handled by the slower high
bandwidth memory all of this is where we
get the term Hardware aware State
expansion it's an architecture built
with an awareness of the kind of gpus
it's going to run on let's try to make
this more tangible with an example of
what we can achieve with all of this
free up complexity take this induction
head comparison first take the word
explained which is made up of two tokens
expor and aimed an induction head is a
circuit that might be attending to the
token expor and its function is to scan
the existing sequence for previous
examples of that token that it's
attending to then it needs to find the
token that in that survey came after the
token which in our case will be AED and
then forecast that that will happen once
more to give us EXP explained obviously
you need to be great at recoil to do
this especially if the sequence involves
thousands hundreds of thousands or even
millions of tokens other architectures
fall apart as the sequence length gets
longer than that found in training but
not mber look at the Top Line accuracy
staying at one even up to a million
tokens and remember that architectures
like Mamba need not necessarily hunt
alone take this announcement of striped
hyena from together AI they showed that
we need not necessarily choose with a
hybrid architecture involving attention
performing well but there's one more
thing before we put the mamba snake back
into the basket on the left you can see
its Superior performance at great apes
DNA classification in other words
deciding whether a sequence of DNA was
human chimpanzee gorilla orangutang or
bonabo notice that it's on the longest
sequence lengths that its performance
starts to really shine this task by the
way they made artificially hard for
themselves because it was originally
about distinguishing between a human
lemur Mouse Pig and hippo but you could
easily imagine other use cases like
healthcare you could rapidly analyze a
patient's genetic data and come up with
personalized medical treatment for them
more speculatively you could imagine a
chat bot that remembers a conversation
you had months or years ago and then of
course I'll leave it to you to think of
all the other long sequences out there
like stock market data or weather data
and as I mentioned before video data
from those long video explainers that
annoy everyone but wait is this video
becoming one of those I really hope not
so I'm going to move on to the next
reason that AI is not slowing down
anytime soon that is inference time
compute or the ability of the model as
Arthur mench said to decide how much
compute to allocate to certain problems
now I touched on this in my qar video
but here's Lucas Kaiser one of the
authors of the trans former architecture
and indeed a senior figure for open AI
for reasoning you also need these chains
of thought that that like you need the
give the model the ability to think
longer than than it has
layers and but but it can be combined
with multimodel especially when you have
a m like nowadays models they can like
generate you say okay how does it look
when a boy kicks a ball and you can
generate a few frames of the video and
now more and more they mod that will
generate the whole video uh and and then
there start to be models of the world
that say well if you drive a car like
this how will the street look how will
the people look what will happen will
you crash into something so so so in the
future the models will have this
knowledge of the world and this
generation which we call Chain of
Thought in text but but multimodality
this means just it's a chain of frames
of what's going to happen to the world
which is basically how we sometimes
think so so it will be multimodality and
dis ability to generate sequences of
things before you give an answer that
that will resemble much more what we
call reasoning for more on that check
out my qstar video but here's another
taster this is from gnome Brown also of
open AI he admitted that letting models
think for longer would occasionally have
drawbacks inference at times may be a,x
slower and more costly but he said what
inference cost would we pay for a new
cancer drug or for proof of the rean
hypothesis Alpha code 2 which I've also
done a video on gives us a foraste of
the kind of results that we might expect
and remember this is separate from data
quality or dynamic new architectures but
we can't mention Alpha code 2 and
inference time compute without also
mentioning let's verify step by step AKA
process-based verification but I know
what you're wondering what is this graph
and where does it come from well it
comes from a fascinating new paper
entitled AI capabilities can be
significantly improved without expensive
retraining in a way this paper sums up
the message of this video we are not
even close to being done with the
exponential gains in Ai and the way that
this paper measured it was fascinating
it basically asked how much extra
computing power would we have to provide
to get the equivalent gain that these
methods provide as you can see the
methods are quite diverse and almost all
of them have been covered before on this
channel things like prompting and
Scaffolding a bit like smart GPT tool
use or indeed data quality as we saw
with Ora and self-consistency if you're
not familiar with either Orca or
self-consistency and majority voting
check out the videos that I've done
before Linked In the description the
x-axis by the way is the one-time
compute cost that these methods entail
yes some of them go up to 1% or even 10%
as a fraction of the training compute
used to create the models but look at
the the Returns on the Y AIS having a
verifier check the steps of a model does
cost
0.01% as a fraction of the training
compute but the compute equivalent gain
is around N9 in other words you would
have had to use nine times as much
compute on the base model to achieve
similar results and yes many of these
methods can indeed be combined indeed
that's what smart GPT was all about it
was combining Chain of Thought few
shotting and major it voting in 2024 we
may see the F2 data quality approach
combined with say the Mamba architecture
and all of this is before we scale the
models up as the paper says gains from
enhancements and gains from scaling
might interact and compound in
non-trivial ways and they give the
example that Chain of Thought prompting
didn't even work on smaller models I
remember saying toward the end of my
smart GPT video in August that we need
to find out the ceiling of the models
not just the floor and the authors
concur saying researchers could also
study whether there is a seiling to the
total Improvement you can get from
posttraining enhancements that will
enable the AGI labs to better predict
how much more capable their model might
become in the future now I know what
some veteran researchers will be
thinking while looking at these charts
surely it depends on the task and The
Benchmark and the models and all of
these numbers must be very approximate
and of course you are right but I have
have one more critique in addition to
that and that is the third or is it
fourth to be honest I've lost count
reason why AI is going to continue to
improve dramatically and that is prompt
optimization I spoke to Tim rocktashel
of Google deepmind about this for
patreon but this is what I mean in a
nutshell language models can optimize
their own prompts there are many
techniques for doing this but the manual
methods we're coming up with the
heuristics like this is important for my
career and my grandma wants me to do
this are our manual feeble approaches
once we deploy llms to help us optimize
the prompts going into llms we might see
dramatically better performance indeed
we already have for things like high
school mathematics and movie
recommendations anyway this is the
simplified version do check out that
video but the point is this even if we
weren't going for dramatically better
data quality Dynamic new architectures
and getting models to reason and think
for longer then prompt optimization
would allow us to squeeze out
significantly better results even from
existing models and notice I've got
through the whole video without yet
mentioning of course scaling the models
up to 10 trillion parameters or indeed
100 trillion parameters as promised by
eted AI I've got much more information
about them coming soon but let's say
you're someone who doesn't care about
stats benchmarks or indeed AGI
countdowns maybe you're someone who is
skeptical about tweets like this from an
open AI employee who said brace
yourselves AGI is coming well even for
you 2024 looks set to be a dramatic year
these outputs from the Walt team at
Google may be low resolution but they're
quite High consistency I use pabs and
Runway ml2 and the progress season on
season is quite something to watch and
that would be a prediction ad make for
before the end of 2024 I think we will
get a 3 to 5c photorealistic text video
output that could fool most humans now
you might say oh I'd never be fool but
let's test you on that with text to
image which of these then is the real
Roman Arch one of them is from mid
Journey version 6 upscaled with magnific
and the other is a real Arch the answer
is that the one on the left is the real
Roman Arch now in my Christmas video
while misspelling some prompts I did
show off the style raw input this is for
anyone using mid Journey version 6 but
since then from Reddit I found an even
better tip use the phrase phone photo
you can get as you can see strikingly
realistic images and of course you can
further upscale any of these too you can
definitely get some quite interesting
results this way and at this point I
want to show you this quite fascinating
prediction made a 100 years ago this is
what the cartoonist Harold Tucker
Webster thought the world of drawing
would be like in 2023 now yes we're dat
into 2024 but I still think this is
interesting notice the drawing is being
done automatically and the caption is in
the year 2023 when all our work is done
by electricity he called it the cartoon
Dynamo we call it mid Journey version 6
but tomato tomato it's time now to draw
the video to an end but I'm going to end
where I started and know I don't just
mean this tweet from Jim fan I also mean
the words I used in the introduction and
here via 11 lab is me in quotes AI
explained Phillip who is a real person
and not GPT 5 or 6 as some assume but
here's the AI version of my voice
delivering the intro I hope everyone
watching had an excellent 2023 and is
looking to get 2024 off to a
rambunctious start this video though has
been made to show that we are on the
Steep part of the exponential and will
be for a while yet just for fun for all
of my legendary supporters on patreon
I'm going to process this entire video
so you can hear how good AI is getting
at imitating the human voice soon it may
be impossible to tell who's human and
who's not using audio alone and then
soon thereafter even video but I know
you guys know that I'm real so thank you
so much for watching all the way to the
end and as always have a wonderful day
and a wonderful 2024